each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
start this a second talk second session
about the venison with two experiences
to real-world experiences that
correspond to to a scenario that have
been implemented implementing
applications in different area the first
one is called drug design experiment in
the clothes that will be given by Paul
for sorry for Simon Buckman from the
Newcastle University and we work that
the demonstrate the use of workflows in
this ministry infrastructure for a
specific problems of life science and
the practicalities thanks in a sec s so
I'm southern Whitman I work in your
caster University and this is work that
has been supervised by Paul Watson and
done as a combination of myself hyuga
hidin who's here and going to help me
with a demo later on and yeah check Cala
who before she isn't here today so what
we're going to talk about is is our
scenario with in vina see which is to do
with drug development and my background
is I'm a computer scientist I'm not I'm
not a drug developer but we work with
people at the northern Institute cancer
research in Newcastle and also the
pharmacology Department in in the
University of Sunderland and so
releasably the use case has been driven
by those scientists we've just been
implementing it I said I'll talk to that
scenario i'll then go on to where we
were before we start the Venus II
project and give you some a bit of
background about that well then have a
look at the architecture that we've
implemented within Venus see then
assuming we've got time I'll talk about
a provenance capture system that we've
built which is particular interest in
the drug development scenario and
quickly give a quick demo of that and
finally
mentioned bit of future work so the key
the key question that that our
colleagues in in chemistry want to
answer is what are the properties of a
given given molecule for instance how
toxic is it how soluble is it in blood
what sort of biological activities it
does it do and so historically the the
way to the way to ascertain this was to
perform experiments however performing
experiments is is sometimes necessary
and ultimately necessary but at the
early stage it's time-consuming it's
very expensive and there may or may not
be ethical constraints and I little
fluffy bunny at the bottoms and doesn't
generally like it very much so the
alternative is to utilize a technique
called kuser quantitative
structure-activity relationship and it
basically says what what mathematical
function in terms of solubility does
this molecule possess and there are
different ways to quantify that molecule
it could be in terms of its the number
of atoms in it its shape and their
adapter a 3000 or more than 3000 so
recognized ways of describing this
molecule and we call those descriptors
so assuming that we can calculate those
descriptors we need some base data to
take and for the purpose of these
experiments we've been using some open
source databases namely something called
Campbell and wombat and the key thing in
these databases they all have some some
data in in there that represents the
chemical structure usually in terms of
sweet God smiles which sir textual
representation of the compound and they
have some sort of value that's been
measured in previous experiments that
describes what that what that compound
did with respect to certain properties
so q SARS its basis of the regression
exercise first of all we partition the
training and test data from the from
these databases so we're going to be
building models of it we then calculate
the the various descriptors and we don't
use all three thousand that we use sort
of 100 couple hundred different ones we
then need to select which which of those
descriptors are suitable to build models
from and we're looking for things that
aren't too correlated otherwise they
don't tend to build particularly good
models then we build the models and
finally add them to the database and now
we automate this this cuse our process
and one of the one of the unique things
about our our particular use cases that
there are multiple ways of performing
each of these actions so there are
different ways you can partition the
training and test data there are lots of
different descript calculators you can
use to influence in different languages
different licensing there are different
ways of picking which descriptors are
going to use different different
algorithms to determine that and finally
there are lots of different types of
models that we can build and so that the
type of workflow we start with looks a
bit like a tree so we start with one
input data set at the top and we then
have different ways of partitioning it
and we do a brute force approach that we
try each different way of partitioning
it then for each of those we calculate
all the descriptors that are necessary
for each of those sets of descriptors
and we correlate them and throw out the
ones that are too correlated and then
finally we build lots of models for each
of the each of the sets descriptors so
to imagine this tree structure and where
one data set at the top results in in 40
to 50 models so that's the the abstract
workflow that we have for dealing with
this um so what do we have before we
started with Venus see we were working
with some people who had a legacy system
for performing this operation called the
discovery bus and and it was it was
build
from an Oracle database and we we
changed it slightly so that the Oracle
database instead of feeding sort of
local local service to do the
computation we we created a proxy local
server that actually shifted the work to
Windows Azure and we had a bunch of
working load in as your that crunched
the data and then everything went back
into this of the bus master make the
main database and that that worked but
the problem we had was that it didn't
scale in any way whatsoever so so if we
look at this graph this this basically
said how many models per minute the
system was building we tested up to 90
odd worker nodes that's that's these
things sort of over here although they
were all running in as your and we found
that after well I mean after about 40 we
actually got worse performance so
although we had this this illusion of
infinite resource in the cloud we
couldn't make use of it that was our
that was our starting point in vina see
we had we had something running within
this year and but we couldn't make use
of the resources available so within
beingness see we've taken the the legacy
system and we've updated it so it's the
first thing we did was we took away the
the discovery bus although we kept the
the same sort of abstract workflows and
we kept the same computation that was
happening each step and we ported it on
something called a science central which
I'll discuss in a minute and we then we
changed the the level of granularity
that the parallelism was was happening
at so within the discovery bus every
single block in a workflow was being
scheduled to run on it on a particular
machine and a lot of these these blocks
and the workflows were very very quick
to run they were just performing a
little bit of data manipulation and
obviously some of them were more
computationally
but there were a lot of a very cheap
blocks to room and so we changed the
unit of parallelism so we now actually
operate on a workflow level and the
whole of the workflow is is assigned to
assign to a machine so that means that
the the application is less chatty term
from the server and I'll show you some
results later on that we've actually got
sort of quite a lot of quite a lot of
speed up so II south central very
briefly is a platform for the
cloud-based data analysis it has has a
notion of sort of data that's stored
within it which is is versioned and
secure so it has access rights built in
we can write workflows to process that
data and the components when the
workflows can be written either jar are
octave or JavaScript and we'll see a
demo of if some of these workflows
running later on that's doing some of
the modeling so within Venus see we've
taken this Isan central system and we've
deployed it into a virtual machine as
your and then we've deployed workflow
engines into the generic worker an hour
our use case for genet workers is
slightly strange or different to other
people certainly because we we deploy a
workflow engine which is a very long
running task into the genic worker we've
got a prototype for CDM I've the data
access although that's that's in very
early stages and with regards comp SS
running it on the barcelo supercomputer
we've got a prototype implementation
there
so this this diagram sort of it looks
similar but much more abstract the ones
that good was showing earlier with the
idea is that we've got this virtual
machine role in south central which is
able to submit jobs and manage workflows
VAR a cube and then intergenic worker we
we submit a job which is a workflow
engine that talks to the central server
running in the virtual machine and
internally uses local storage process
the workflows and the results are put
into blob and table store and so what we
can do is we can have 11 virtual machine
which is running the south central
server and we can then scale these these
generic workers up and down depending on
the load and we found this gives very
very good performance results so this is
a slightly different graph to last time
what it shows is house you have more
nodes to the system an ideal one hundred
percent speed up would be the green line
there and we were actually achieving
about a 80-82 tenth speed up and so as
we've got 100 machines in the system is
performing eighty percent as fast as it
should theoretically and in terms of a
comparison with the original discovery
bus this is this orange line is that is
the same the same data set we saw
earlier a request for minute or so
models built per minute and the slightly
lighter line is that is the new system
and so we can see that there's about a
six-fold increase in the performance
that we're seeing from from this system
and so it was the way that it was doing
the scheduling and so because it was
very chatty if you had a component that
was very quick to operate within azure
it was then sending data backs there was
a lot of data transfer and then the
coordination software had to figure out
what it had what needed to be done next
and then sheduled that and there was a
although each one didn't take
particularly long there were an awful
lot of them and so by by having the
level of parallelism over of a workflow
there's a lot lower load on the server
and because the workflow runs and then
transfers the end results back so so
within a Venus II project and we've seen
this we've seen the speed up and use the
generic worker has hopefully allowed us
to be able to more easily port it across
to other other architectures as well we
haven't yet started looking at running
it on the emotive cloud directly but I
think there's a generic worker
implementation the pipeline that would
allow us to do that so the last section
the talk is going to be about provenance
capture and really sort of why it's
important within the drug development
scenario and and how we do it and we'll
see a demo as well so for drug
development it's important that we can
capture both the data and the process so
we want to be able to answer questions
such as for a particular model how was
it generated which algorithm was used
which sets of descriptors and how
reproducible are these results it
slightly more generically we're looking
at sort of how how bugs have manifested
in the system so if we find out
particular version of a service has a
bug in it how which models have been
affected by that book
and can we can we regenerate those
models using a newer version of the
service which is in theory bug free so
within e south central there are various
different ways of accessing it so
there's a website and there's an API and
then there's a separate API that the
workflow engines use and we need to be
able to capture provenance for all of
those all of those aspects it has to be
caught at the core of e side central the
way that we the way that we capture
provenance all the way that we store it
is in a graph database called neo4j the
reason we do that is that a provenance a
provenance trace is inherently a graph
structure and so storing a database that
that is intended for graphs seems like a
good idea the graph database instead of
having a notion of tables and rose it
has it has notions of no's relationships
between them and instead of clearing it
you traverse it so we built some some
libraries for interacting with these
based on the open provenance model and
there's also a rest interface to it
which allows us to perform some
traversals so so very quickly what's it
looked like will for the same abstract
workflow that we had before if we've got
a model has been built it's been built
by a model builder workflow and it used
a descriptor file as input and the
structure of that workflow has an
internal structure which is also
representatives as part of the graph so
you can see it's just it's a directed
graph
now eyes are a bit more complicated in
that because these are some of the the
actual workplace we use and what happens
is that the workflow at the top it does
some work gets a set of results and then
shedule one of the middle workflows for
every every line in the results file and
the same happens in the middle workflow
where it does some work I think this
one's not sure what this one's actually
do to it doesn't work to manipulate the
data compute some hands and functions
and then for each of the results of the
output of those functions calls a number
of the bottom level workflows to end up
this tree structure with with links
between the all the work place and what
we want to be able to do is given it
given a provenance trace we want to be
able to reconstruct one virtual workflow
that spans multiple physical workflows
and I've been given a five minute
warning so i'm i'm sort of rushing a
little bit and the way the way that we
do that is that the top workflow their
imports a file then it calls a service
and exports it this second workflow
takes the beam takes as its input the
output of the previous workflow and then
did some more processing and we end up
with the result first thing we do to
construct a virtual workflow is we
removed the various data items because I
workflow send data directly from one
service to another and to end it with
this middle one and then because we want
to join these together we remove the
export file and the input import file
and join them together end of this warm
one virtual workflow here ink I'm
actually running a little bit short of
time for demo but if anyone would like a
demo then please grab me I'm here sort
of for the the rest of the week and so
so future work sort of in terms of
integration with the Venus see platform
we're looking at sort of migrating it to
other providers and working more within
the compass s side of things
improving improving CDM I and eat in the
traffic redundancy protocol illy was
talking about because we don't have
particularly large files but we have a
lot of little files and there's a real
amount of duplication in there so we
think that the traffic redundancy
elimination could actually give us some
quite big benefits and also looking at
the integration with the accounting and
audit services from the provenance side
of things because we know how long the
individual services within the workflow
took to run we're looking at building
models of the workflow to bridge it to
predict future resource requirements so
that we can estimate ahead of time in an
hour we're going to need a whole bunch
more generic workers brought up and so
we can bring those up ahead of time and
also shut them down when there's less
work so that's it any any questions so
the sun central system was already using
postgres whereas the discovery bus was
using oracle yeah question
it's it's quite generic for other types
of applications as long because they
don't require integration with a human
so it's not particularly good at sort of
a workflow where you require some human
human input halfway through yes so we're
working with people who are doing
analysis of physical activity data so
they they capture a lot of sort of X i
XYZ acceleration over a seven day period
and then they're using new Science
Center for the analysis of that there's
various of the amps or data files that
were getting in and doing analysis of
yes we have a notion of a library and a
service can depend on a on a particular
library which could have a different
version of our in it and what happens is
at runtime that particular version of
our is downloaded onto the onto the the
node that's running that work for if
it's not very present and configured and
then run so within a particular workflow
you can have or require different
versions of different languages okay so
I'm also glad to be here with you today
I will bring to to the discussion
different kind of perspective the
perspective of a small company entering
a European research project dealing with
it and coming out with a new spin-off
company then the partner company we will
see is co laboratorio sort of micro
incubator for digital innovation in the
field of architecture green p5 is a
spin-off coming out for this project I
will talk about the spin-off with this
business perspective so green buildings
green buildings is a new emerging market
in the world the the building industry
is leading about fifteen to twenty
percent of the outer hula market of
every kind of
the green building market is a subset is
about one to two percent of the the
whole building industry and it is very
different in size from different kind of
architecture different materials
different size of the building and
different for standards in a local
applications but basically in literature
green building is a building's that has
received a certain certain certain
certification for from Institute's that
deliver those kind of certificate those
are the certification we are so far in
Italy and it's not a particular case is
at the moment a complex panorama of
certification in the world so the market
it's about four hundred billions in 2015
this is the provision from the global
industry analysts made in 2010 and it is
a marketer enlarging of more than five
percent a year and this is the market
where this platform want to enter in the
more providing market our first place
first level China second u.s. third
Europe when I say Europe I'm in Northern
Europe specifically those in the
pictures are all the meetings we have we
have done face to face and you can see
the intensity of the meeting in China
the more polarizing market consider that
the World Bank say that in 2015 I'll for
the of the old building construction
size will be in China so the size of the
market in China is be most of their
needs for green buildings and the
capacity to industrialize the process
because what I'm presenting is a way to
industrialize the building process in
fact our main advisor is professor
chinua from the University and stated
stated out with a with the real problem
England
so we can achieve green buildings but at
the end of the day they will be very
very expensive to be to be realized so
green prefab enable a network to to
achieve a low-cost green buildings so
this is the basic model that the state
under our our solution it means we are
transferring technologies processes
materials from other industrial domains
automotive especially the field and also
aerospace into the building industry so
let all the stakeholders sharing in a
real-time information during the
different phases we have to build a
building and basic basing this
production on an industrial way that is
the prefabrication model it means
creating components prefabricated
components off-site into the factories
so a very very short video that will
introduce you more on this system I give
you background about the building in C
so so nowadays we are exploring the
prefabricated market and we are
integrating already existing commercial
produce into a new digital platform so
we are digitalizing products with a 3d
geometries and we attached information
to its component into our database to
our database where we provide
information about the structural
behavior about the Eco behavior of the
components and and so on and we do that
for different products and we are they
integrate them into a into our platform
it's an open an open platform where we
can we can add a multiple produce
soothing at the end we have a library
already already running with geometries
3d and information attached to them so
that the the Lego system that we provide
through our system to archit as they
stay somewhere in the global village in
the offices and we
those 3d models they compose they create
their architectural concepts using their
own software at the end they will
deliver to the system a whole 3d
building 3d virtual building that will
be available to the next player that in
this case our engineers already waiting
into the into the platform they will
receive 3d models with precise geometry
is connected to production with the
information they need if they are
structural engineers they already have
data where they can they can achieve
their the test easily and giving a
feedback also in a in a speedway at the
end of the process the real estate or in
the private case can can decide that all
the performances are okay so also the
purchase order are directly the ride
from the 3d model where we we know how
many passel of certain kind we have of
another and the production can can start
negotiating times and prices again add s
at that point complex logistic phase
managed by the system and at the end of
the construction site that start with a
corona program that we extrapolate from
from the 3d model where we know each
when it's a prefabricated component has
to arrive before and after with other
pieces who is a with causing delay for
example in the construction site at the
end we deliver to the environment and
also to the market a building that had a
great engineering phase where we
foreseen exactly cause and performances
of the building in generally building
automation system like black boxes in
the airplanes that the comparison will
manage will control and monitor how you
are using this building connected to the
3d model and giving you a reaction and
also as masters as you know on a better
using of this building
so it's a complex is a complex platform
we are we are dealing with the
competences and companies we are dealing
with different I ICT infrastructure and
tools and softwares and when we are also
dealing with the real object that has to
do to be attached one to the other so
database is the the platform the first
phase of the platform we see the concept
engineering involving architects and
engineers production off-site into
factories and on-site for assembling in
construction site and operational of the
system so this is a PLM for building
English so a product lifecycle
management system going through all the
phases till the dismantling of the
building and we can compute all the
advantages on these whole life of the
building and so I during the period of
the project we were already studying
since two years this kind of models and
facing the first clients and
stakeholders interested in that during
the project and with the booth or what
we have done in VLC we decided to
establish the company with with my
partner arranged that a Beretta farello
and a boarded advisor that is growing
let me just make sure professor Vladimir
but the Annika from the department of
energy in u.s. one of the founder of
energy plus that is a software for
eco-efficiency analogy and also of IFC
that is the interoperable format for
cod4 3d models that we are using of
course we have also established a
relationship in Vienna see with micro
servers any project omani fedora you
will see later that they are providing
as the first pilot cases to be built we
are coming out from from European
research projects they that were the the
the morning we used to develop so far
this system one was about database
ontology and
semantic relations between between data
in the specific domain of architecture
maze meta data for our guitar contest
needed by fraunhofer institute and then
a vino see where we are implementing
cloud computing for the engineering
phase so cloud computing is required by
engineers within our system those are
the three first modules we are
developing we enter the project for the
rendering in G so we need we needed to
visualize simply our project with a
single picture with movies or we with
the mercy real-time environments and it
takes a lot of time to do to do those
kind of simulation so we we enter with
this scenario it happens that another
part another partner from from Valencia
University of Valencia we are leading
the canary on structural analysis and a
pilot case from the open pole you have
seen in the presentation we had an open
call involving 50 new pilot new motion
Aereo's proposed building energy
simulation so what we are doing is
packing it on a single platform for
delivering a full surface for engineers
so this is about our rendering engine
from our platform people download
architects download 3d building
components they import in different
shortcut software maybe you have
mentioned you know about being Building
Information modelling rabbit ArchiCAD
allplan microstation we deliver the Lego
system in all those formats but if you
have Sketchup that is for free you can
you can use it and then you turn back
the model to the system and we we use
lacks render for creating the rendering
last render word was selected because
was open source so compiled also in a
way that we can understand how it work
it was the first software we ported into
the cloud
at the end it is now running in in two
versions one is related to microsoft
windows azure infrastructure and in
services so it's already running the the
first public release to a community we
own in italy that is about to 20,000
architects a subset of them of course we
will start using this this application
for rendering visualization i will now
go inside this architecture but we
basically use a web role where people
upload their files but i will show you
the video on how it works so this is the
green prefab demo platform available
online you enter with your own
credentials so you say where you want to
create that project and which is your
group and you start downloading from the
3d library they produce you you prefer
and you need to do well for your project
that are also parametrically
parametrically so they can change in
size and inform also even in finishers
in materials they import into this off
20 in this case with in sketchup and
where they have a control of the
architectural shape and basic
information about materials they don't
have all the information for engineer
here they upload the system they upload
the components into the system it will
provide some files and some some some
some forms whether they can select
different size of the final image the
quality the time of rendering and this
is the first application that it is
running so far in Windows Azure at the
end it will let me skip a little bit at
the end it will provide a result result
page where the architect said there
their own pics or they are waiting with
the rendered materials and and lights
but the same infrastructure has been
developed also with the Barcelona
supercomputer com superscalar is an
infrastructure they have in Barcelona
and it was not a problem to involve a
similar a similar model of production
even based on unlocks render for this
for this kind of infrastructure even
using GPU clusters the other partner we
are integrating into the green prefab is
developing architrave that is a software
for structural analysis and they are
developing with envy no see the
application on on Windows Azure and then
will be easy connecting to to this kind
of platform well and finally this is the
most recent application that is the
equal efficiency analysis we are
integrated also the the most data
intensive application it comes out from
a pilot from the royal danish academy in
copenhagen and it is attracting a lot of
interest around it for energy plus and
also a specialized and customized
version of this energy plus called je
plus consider for this kind of
application for one building nowadays
they have to test it for eco-efficiency
analogy means energy savings and
compliancy for different certification
models and protocols they are running
different tests changing the facade that
the window facade cindy the position of
the building and they are doing dozens
of those of those all those tests
nowadays though then those ends means
about two days today's a full
computation on on on a four-story
building for example with this system
they want to test for the first time
more than 10,000 tests using the cloud
so we will we will have a great mass of
different option to automatically select
the best solution in the beating then
projeto many futur i mentioned before in
italy is his place is a new techno pole
that was established early this year so
it's very new with nine hectares in
dimension and it is placed in trentino
province that is an autonomous province
in italy autonomous means that ninety
percent of the taxes stays on into the
proteins and they add delivers services
to their people in population with those
money also hospitals and schools so an
island with in Italy fortunately we're
happens that this techno pole decided
that green prefab can be of interest for
them using the venue see a cloud
application the community we have a two
thousand architects in Italy and
involving a BTech that is a district of
about 200 companies they have already in
that in place working for sustainable
products in in building industry they
already as a province so as local
government decided to to use green
building council an institute that is
there in Italy that providing the LEED
certification maybe you maybe know
because it not only the most diffusing
America man in the world in you a slit
in the world and other kind of
certification they they locally decide
to implement on the other side that
there is the economic part the part that
is CNR
valve that is delivering the technology
they they promised intends to support
and to use in they in the local region
that they attack the teaser technology
made by wood called croslin a specific
structural component you can use for
walls and for for all the parts
structural parts of the building and
those are the first test we are we are
we have been working in in the last two
years and these are in different places
in the world difference in sizes the
pilot casing that you know we give out
the first real building that will be
built in Italy in this case and we are
easier to have one full developed
building within the system prefabricated
component prefer brocaded panel this
this morning from father I have seen an
interesting picture about data centers
that were perfectly compliant with this
kind of off idea so I opened the future
to add here some sand testing about
those building very short unveiling
about the business model that will be
that let us to deliver this platform for
free for different stakeholders and
instead we will have negotiation about a
three percent of each transaction that
will happen within this system basically
put sales orders to pre fabricators
within the suppliers and real estates
and then of course there is training and
there are customized version and a lot
of other not bid
as a result the prototype the first
approach and then we will see the
product prototype is online if you have
to do whether Luke go to green prefab
calm and enjoy the platform let's go
there are a lot of advantage is
different from each of the players I
have showed you the the biggest
advantages that is also creating this
business model is for those guys for
real states or even public entities that
has to create to build socialism then
the main advantage of this kind of
system is that you can control costs you
can control performances and you can
control costs with that my father is a
local builder contractor and work in the
traditional way in the north of Italy
when a traditional way means eighty
percent or all of the the market in the
world not oh not only in our small
village with that traditional system
when you start a building you cannot
foresee exactly how much will it cost at
the end you will disc when I go to van
cool that is the biggest real estate in
China and I say that probably they have
about ten percent of unexpected costs at
the end they say that ten percent is
it's okay some time is not enough it is
more so with this system we can control
the cost because we're working with an
industrial model and we can say those
ten percent and that better be a bigger
result at the same time we can control
the other performances for for
eco-efficiency for energy-saving for
example so that advantage you also with
the we can speed up time with the kind
of production that is prefabrication and
with the technologies we use and with
the network we are enabled and the
platform let's share people specifically
for cloud the advantage is time with
time because now for the different
analogy they took it if they want to
make ten thousand experiments they will
last for one mouth now they cannot they
cannot do it they will be a
able to do into 12 days a cloud
infrastructure what have you done
running that on on a cluster running
that on on your laptop and what anyway
you're ready anticipating that you take
months yeah yeah yeah faster on a
cluster yeah yes yes and on a laptop you
have to go test by test you make one
test then you create a new set of data
and you make the second test manually we
are still in this phase so what I'm
saying with it with my contribution that
building industry is an is in a
revolution period and he's really nice
in needs of need of new ICT tools and
platform aggregating new open networks
within so there is a there is really a
huge work to do on this domain
thank you